we are learning more about the
terrorists who killed 43 people
including 19 foreigners at Istanbul's
airport the security camera image
reportedly shows all three suicide
bombers just before the attack CBS News
confirms the men are not Turkish CIA
director John Brennan says the attack
bears the hallmarks of isil's depravity
ISIL is another name for Isis no one has
claimed responsibility raids in Turkey
overnight reportedly swept up more than
a dozen suspects Holly Williams is at
Istanbul's atatürk airport with a new
look at the attackers right before they
launch their assault Holly good morning
good morning Turkish media is reporting
that one of the suicide bombers was
Chechen and came here from raka the
so-called Isis capital in Syria one
report is even naming him as Osman vatta
naã¯ve though at this point there is no
official confirmation of that the taxi
driver who dropped the three attackers
here at the international terminal has
apparently told investigators that they
were speaking a foreign language that he
didn't recognize other reports suggest
that all three men were foreign two of
the attackers were able to force their
way past airport security and they then
blew themselves up inside the terminal
building a third attacker detonated his
suicide vest here at the entrance and
you can still see damage from the blast
behind me it appears that most of the
victims were Muslims killed by an act of
terrorism during the Islamic holy month
of Ramadan but despite those police
raids on Isis suspects the group still
has not claimed responsibility for this
massacre at Istanbul's main airport Nora
all right Holly Williams who's there at
the airport in Istanbul thank you